[Musique]
bonjour c'est véronique jannot sur
ina.fr
parce que le tennis et le témoignage des
gens et la façon dont ils ont un don ils
m'ont accueilli surtout sa voix là on
sent tout simplement que c'était
tellement présent dans leur vie dans
leur coeur dont j'ai accompagné dé
d'aider des millions de gens en fait
avec pause-café ça a touché au moins
deux générations si ce n'est trois c'est
vrai il ya quelquefois des jeunes de 20
ans de rôle la cci père est émouvant
c'est très touchant
j'en ai marre je suis l'une relative
quand tu nous tiens w l'assistante
sociale
on va le rôle était formidable le rôle
serge leroy qui est un metteur en scène
le producteur s'était c'était osé je
dire c'était vraiment c'était sacrément
osé de m une pause café qui avait l'air
d'avoir l'âge de ses élèves s'étaient
c'était un pari quand même de décaler
l'idée qu'on pouvait se faire à l'époque
de nous-mêmes aujourd'hui d'ailleurs
d'une assistante sociale et c'était je
trouve que c'était tellement nouveau
s'était gonflée mais je pense qu'on peut
dire que c'était circulent tout et c'est
bien au delà d'un succès ça a été un
phénomène social pause-café
elle était à la fois moderne elle était
en même temps tendre il y avait de
l'humour des vrais sentiments
c'était très bien joué donc forcément il
ya une quantité folle de gens qui ont vu
ce feuilleton mais il a correspondu
vraiment à un reflet de la société à une
attente des gens
c'était certainement un peu le maître
étalon d'autres séries qui ont suivi
c'était une cité ce rôle social c'est
écoutes ce rôle porteur d'espoir en fait
les gens étaient entendus ils
retrouvaient leurs problèmes et dont
c'était c'est ça les gens pouvaient s'y
retrouver car qui n'a fait et je trouve
que enfin il me semble qu'en tout cas
d'aidé même des sujets
qui sont complètement d'aujourd'hui
complètement moderne et que même on
aurait du mal à aborder aujourd'hui
pourquoi ce que vous dites que c'est un
petit voyou vous savez vous avez quelque
chose de raciste et on est allé tourner
dans les banlieues et j'ai parlé avec
les gens j'ai été avec les jeunes
réellement on a tourné on sait pas du
décor et je j'ai pris conscience de cet
environnement que je connaissais pas
tous les problèmes qui sont abordés sont
des problèmes vire cette année des faits
réels c'était des choses qui existaient
tous les jours dans les banlieues et
ailleurs seront aussi un voile opaque
les banlieues où il ya des choses pas
nettes qui ce qui se passait qui se
passe aujourd'hui dans tomb jsk une
grande différence entre jouer le mozart
et par exemple docteur claire bellac et
ben non et vous aujourd'hui ben non tu
attends attends je crois que j'ai la
chance que la vie mais garder mon mon
enthousiasme et cette passion en fait
pour pour la vie pour pour les
rencontres pour les gens de quoi vous
mêlez vous de moi mais qui me fait le
proviseur est ce que si on vous
proposait une une quatrième série de
pause-café vous verriez oui oui je dirai
oui voilà ce serait forcément différente
on l'adaptera différemment mais bon oui
et non en fait
en même temps je dirais que
l'enthousiasmé et la passion n'a pas
d'âge et qu'on peut quand on a décidé
d'abattre des montagnes on peut en tout
cas commencé à gravir la colline et puis
on sait jamais où ça nous mène c'est la
passion qui voit là quand on a une vraie
envie il faut y aller il faut écouter
son coeur et puis de toute façon sur ce
chemin là on trouve toujours des choses
formidables
aujourd'hui je la jouerai peut-être plus
consciente de l'importance de ce que un
personnage comme ça peut porter parce
que là parce qu'un médias comme la
télévision doit se servir de sa
puissance de frappe de sa force de
frappe pour dire des choses essentielles
qui apporte aux gens pas pour les amener
vers des choses minables qu'on peut voir
comment certaines des rallyes
téléréalité moi qui me navre
profondément j'ai eu le disais je le
redis scandale à manger à notre faim
aujourd'hui au niveau de leurs de leur
richesse intellectuelle avec la
télé-réalité c'est lamentable
qu'est-ce que je
naturellement hier soir tout le monde a
regardé la télé j'ai regardé la télé ya
aussi des clubs il y avait un super si
vous avez envie d'aller retrouver une
époque mais qui n'est pas si finalement
si loin parce que cette série
terriblement moderne c'est certainement
cette série qui a changé engagé ma vie
en tout cas de d'une certaine façon
alors je vous conseille d'aller d'aller
la voir elle avait regardé pause-café
je suis sûr qu'on serait touchée
[Musique]